welcome voice activation required for  access denied god of thunder tonight  strongest Avenger tonight let me try  Berner welcome strongest Avenger oh what  the goddess of death destroyed your  hammer like a piece of glass  [Applause]  before your queen the entire universe  was in jail  and putting together a team to stop us  made of rocks you don't need to be  afraid unless you're made of scissors I  want to be on the team has a car named  the hero revenge's revenge us because  I'm getting revenge and you're getting  revenge you on revenge and decided  I want to see what true power really  looks like  you can't defeat me joy  thor ragnarok biggest muscle in the body  i've got lots of muscles so technically  more brains  pg-13 melon everywhere